man that Mandalorian baits in my head I
like it episode 3 of the Mandalorian
it's hit Disney Plus I saw it now I
talked about see there's like spoilers
on this one too I don't tell you exactly
what happens but there's some
implication and there's enough to where
it's like yet take half an hour out of
your day go watch it and come back here
get my thoughts so this being a 30
minute long episode again this is not
much to talk about but there's enough to
talk about in this episode the 30 minute
timeframe it didn't bother me as much
probably because I've been binging
gargoyles which let's face it that's the
best reason to get Disney Plus if you're
kind of get it you got some good stuff
on there but it's like Batman the
Animated Series which is not a Disney
Plus in gargoyles those are like
top-tier 90s animations granted
spider-man x-men the other ones but
those are top two for me but in this
episode again simple premise he's going
to turn in the package and he has to
decide whether or not he's okay with
that it's gonna hold to the code alright
yeah the codes the code the jobs the job
or he's gonna have a crisis of
conscience about it which is hope it's a
great thing to put your characters
through because you know we've got to
see some humanity there's thing about
the Mandalorian is that he he shows a
lot of that humanity throughout the show
so far these three episodes the thing
you get is that he's not just some
unstoppable badass Mandalorian there's
even a scene in here where there are a
lot of other Mandalorians in the room
with him and you're like God just by
looking at them and by attitude you feel
like these guys are bigger than him and
maybe he could beat them in a fair fight
but it really does feel like the jocks
surrounding just the average kid in
school maybe the average kid can throw
down and know how to fight but he's not
the biggest of them you don't feel like
he's like I'm some unstoppable
Mandalorian badass sent know my religion
is built around armor and weapons yes
that's how I carry myself I'm the
biggest and the best it just looks like
a normal dude who just happens to be a
Mandalorian graduate I don't know much
about my Mandalorian Laura I'll be the
first to admit it so maybe you can help
me out but even then the flashbacks
where it shows who I assumed or his
parents running from droids they don't
seem to be wearing Mandalorian armor so
I don't know at what point you pick up
the Mandalorian armor and now that your
religion but it really feels like he
wasn't born into it he just kind of
adopted it at an older age in every
episode of the Mandalorian so far all
three of them he has run into a
situation that's too much for him
other force that gets him out of it he
worked with IG 11 to get out of the
situation in episode wine without Yoda
baby raising the big Rhino he'd have
died in Episode two I love the fact that
he was gonna go out with his little
butter knife but he was still gonna die
yo what a baby got him out of it and
this episode the same thing happens he's
in a firefight that's too much for him
he cannot get out of it I like the fact
that this show shows that mortality with
the Mandalorian not that he's not badass
in a fight he's completely shown that he
is but he doesn't try to step up to
people and try to posture like he is the
biggest and the best generally speaking
he just wants to do the job get paid and
go home this is why this episode
character why is it so important in a
weird way he kind of reminds me of
Malcolm Reynolds from Firefly he's not
the biggest dude but he's badass in his
own right and for the most part you
leave him alone he'll leave you alone
he's gotta need to beat you he just
wants to be on his leg but he has a
bigger heart than maybe even he thought
he had and that heart is no doubt gonna
get him wrapped up in something much
bigger and a lot of that credits from
the personality that comes through
mostly from body language granted with
the scenarios that are written around
him and how he deals with them if that's
actually Pedro Pascal under that helmet
he's doing good work and that's got me
loving this show so three episodes in
I'm diggin the mandalorian just a guy
and his telepathic Yoda clone baby it
was that the first attempt was that
Palpatine 50 years ago that predates the
Phantom Menace was that Palpatine being
like I've cloned the greatest Jedi of
all time I will make him my apprentice
in a Jedi will what how long does it
take they age that slowly I think I'm
just gonna make a clone army of Jango
Fett warriors and then embed an order
into their brains that I can activate at
the opportune moment yes that's that's
probably quicker so I'm really liking
the Mandalorian I feel like I'm still in
the introductory phase of his character
they could do stuff in this season that
completely makes me go okay or they can
do stuff in season two that does the
same thing but for right now the
Mandalorians one of the more compelling
things I've seen from Star Wars in a
while are so the Mandalorian episode 3
titled the sin have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you
[Music]